en la de presidente yo bailén en un
comunicado dio la bienvenida a gustavo
cárdenas y a jorge fernández tras haber
sido arrestados de forma injustificada
en 2017 y 2021 respectivamente por el
régimen de nicolás maduro estos padres
dijo bailen podrán volver a abrazar a
sus hijos familiares llamados que
sufrieron cada día su ciencia agradeció
el presidente la labor de su enviado
para asuntos de rehenes roger cartens y
del equipo de oficiales que viajó el
pasado sábado a caracas para reunirse
con nicolás maduro y negociar la
liberación de los presos políticos cabe
mencionar que entre estos miembros del
equipo negociador de estadounidense
viajó juan gonzález colombo americano y
director senior de el consejo de
seguridad nacional y también james story
jefe de la unidad de asuntos para
venezuela del departamento de estado
precisamente el secretario de estado-
anthony blinken dijo en un comunicado
que si bien se da la bienvenida a este
paso importante siguen presionando para
que se liberen a todos los ciudadanos
estadounidenses detenidos
injustificadamente en venezuela y en
todo el mundo presión o negociación con
maduro y ha sido muy criticada por
muchos entre ellos el senador
republicano por la florida marco rubio
quien está en campaña de reelección y
que aseguró que si va a ir en hace un
trato con maduro por el petróleo que no
necesita a eeuu habrá condenado a
venezuela a vivir bajo una narco
dictadura durante una generación le
habría dado así un impulso también al
régimen de cuba